た
[音楽]
ます
初
出口何これ何これ
ゼロ1
出口何何これ何これ
わご案内
を異変を見逃さないこと異変を見つけたら
すぐに引き返すこと異変が見つからなかっ
たら引き返さないこと8番出口から外に
出る
ことオレンジどういうことはじめさんには
今からこの家でリアル8番出口をやって
もらいます
なるほどあれかあのゲームか8番出口とは
無限に続く地下通路に閉じ込められて
しまったプレイヤーが8番出口から脱出
することを目指すウォーキング
シミュレーター
ですそれが俺ということか今はいルールは
とても簡単で何か異変を見つけたら地下
通路を引き返し逆に何も異変が見つから
なかったら先へ進むという間違い探しの
ようなものです
あのどさこれ僕ちなんです
けどよくやった
なクオリティすごいゲームのままだけど
これとかであれでしょゲーム通りだったら
異変があって引き返してあってたらこの
数字が増えてくんだよねはいどんどん数字
が増えていきますで間違えたらまた0に
戻るとはいそれをオレンジでやるとそう
です何してくれてんねんさんはいクリア
できないと一生この通路から出られませ
んここですかはいおマジかでもすごいね
実写版8番出口だねただここレチなので8
番出口ですねシえじゃあこれが8になっ
たら俺はもう出れ
るってことにそうですね分かりました
分かりまし
たやってやり
ましょうまずは異変が何もないバージョン
がこれが元ってことねはい分かります
ちゃんと見ていきますよさ行き
ますいや凝ってるねなんで静岡公園
って富山西中学校
エビル4本木4本木交差
点これすごいよよく作った
ねよく作った
[音楽]
よあすごいすごい
すごいあれだ8番出口にいるあれだ会社員
の人だいやリアルや
な
すごいこれもじゃあ何か異変が起きる可能
性があるってことかはいゲーム通りすぎる
な
ちゃんと通路走った後止まるもんあの人
これもちゃん覚えといたいいとことですよ
ね靴とかバックと
か髪型とかも結構オ覚えた覚えた大丈夫
これも変が起きる可能性があると分かり
まし
たさちょっと見ていきますうわこれも
なんか8番ネグのゲームにあった気がする
禁煙の看板とかうわすげえマジ
で番出口になってる俺ん違がすげえ
ポスター貼って
あるこういうのもちゃんと覚えておか
なきゃいけないんだよな熱血青春高木文化
の
花開くこれ誰考えたこれいやすげえ第82
回枝川花火大会だよコナ永遠の思い出を
2024年の8月2日うわ情報量多いなま
ハだね恥はめのハジで覚えます
そしてこっち
が美しいものを美しいと思えるあなたの心
が美しい恥
をだいぶ忠実だ
なポスターとかちゃんとあったもんね本物
の
初口
でここはおおここ出口かでここ出れば
いいってことですねじゃここ出口っぽいの
で出ちゃいますオ覚えた覚えたなんとなく
覚え
たさあ行きます
ねもう始まったよっってこだよねじゃあ
行きますあまあまあまあまあ
いやおじさんは大丈夫そうな気がするけど
な異変を見つけろ
俺何かが変わってるはちょっと待って
よ俺こんな歯並び綺麗だっ
け俺こんな花んだっけいや俺こんななんか
歯を出してしま顔じゃなかった
ぞ
うんこれ異変ですわこれはどう見ても異変
なので引き返し
ますこれで数字が進んで
たら異変あったということですね異変が
なかったらゼロのままでねはい行き
[音楽]
ます
しいやいや当然このレベル来てくくれるん
だったら俺すぐ出ちゃうよなんかゲームだ
から難しい説俺あるのよ8番出口リアル
始まん出口実は簡単じゃないか説があるの
でこれはねさすがに分かりやすかったし
あの技術に驚けましたどうやって俺あんな
出した笑顔にしたのというわけでまずは0
番から1番に来れましたのでこれをあと何
回か正解し続ければ出れるってことねそう
ですじゃあ行きます
ね
失礼し
ますうわすげええどうやったの
これすごい
なずっと同じ表情だそしてマジでそれ
ゲームの世界に入ってうわすごいすごい
すごいこれどうやってんのえっとこれは
これはさっきはに光ってただけでした今回
は点滅してます異変です絶対異変ですこれ
これは絶対異変間違いない2
番
いやすごえそもそもオレンジの1階にああ
いう正面あったっけっていういやけど無事
に今まで来れましたいやいやこの感じだっ
たら俺そこであの出ちゃいますよ大丈夫
ですか
シいやこれからどんどん難しくなるんで
ああなるほどねさすがに難度が上ってき
ますかはい今のところ結構簡単なん
ですやっぱさすがに実写版ということで
簡単なんじゃないかなと思います行きます
ただそろそろ
変化なしが来てもおかしくないような気が
してます
か
[音楽]
う
うん問題
なしあ元々ちょっと光ってるぐらいなの
かほらやっぱ顔戻ってます花火大会も8月
2日
でしょ美しいものを美しいと思えるあんた
のこが美しい恥をいやさっきと一緒な気が
するけどな今の
ところ気をつけろこういうの足元とか天井
とかにも来るから
[音楽]
出口いやいや
いや大丈夫そうだと思うけど
なねこういう穴から誰かが見てるとかそう
いう可能性はある
か
こわ
いや大丈夫じゃないか
ないや大丈夫
これは多分大丈夫
異変なしです今までの異変すごい分かり
やすかったんですけどかっと見ねない気が
するんだよなうんいやこれ大丈夫進みます
異変なし
ですおやった
3だ3番出口まで来れましたてことは今の
は変化が異変がなかったってことですよね
そう
です行きますもう変がある時は分かり
やすくあるない時は本当に何もないとても
分かりやすいやっぱ実写版となると8番
出口簡単なのかもしれません3番行きたい
と思います
よし
[音楽]
あのサラリーマン
の買ったシャツの中の服変わってる説俺
あるんだよ
[音楽]
な
じゃこれでも間違えてるかもしんないから
覚えておこうこのこの感じ
を今の変ですか今違うじゃわかあの
カッターシャツ変わるには分かるけど中の
シャツ変わるやばいぞ行きます
[音楽]
ね
うん多分こんな顔だった気が
するうん花火大会のポスターも問題
[音楽]
なし美しいものを美しいとめるあなたの心
が美しい恥を
うん
こっちも大丈夫
え2連続何もなしちょっと不安だよ
なうん問題なし
えやばいこんなのあったっけってなるよ
ねこんなそちついてたっけう
に
やばわかんねえいやこれ
多分異変ないです多分あの人の服の中の服
がちょっと気になるぐらいですけど多分
異変ない気がするかな異変
なしないよ大丈夫だ本当
にいや多分大丈夫
行き
ます異変
なし
ええ異変あった今
はありまし
たマジ
でおじさんの服の中の服違いますこれ
ちなみにさっき何がいい変かあったかって
聞いてもいいですかそれはまだ答えられ
ません無駄にゲーム通りだな無駄にゲーム
通りだなそういうところばっかりえあった
かまたゼロからじゃんマジで出れない
ちょっと頑張ります行き
ます
ええやっぱ服か服だったの
かめちゃくちゃ笑ってないめちゃくちゃ
笑ってない
めっちゃ笑ってたけどこれ変
ですさっきと比べ
ていやさっき何が違うかをちゃんと分かっ
ておきたいんだよ
ないやだマジでわからんさっきの異変を
ここで調べたいんです
けどいやわからない
ないや分から
ない分からないけども今回の異変は分かり
まし
たここを通ってるおじさんの表情がめちゃ
笑顔でした引き返し
[音楽]
ますよしよしよしよしよしよしこれはね
さすがに分かりましたよしまずはこれで
また1に戻ったとやばいね本当に
俺出れなくなってんじゃん自分の家から
ちょっと頑張りましょうかじゃあもう1回
1番から行きます
[音楽]
さあいやもう完全にここ
でしょえ誰か
いる
これは完全に変だわえまだ1回でしょ
ちょっと頑張んないと戻り
ます
ほよしよしよし戻ってきました2番出口
まで帰ってきましたあと思ったんです
けど実写だからなんか
その8万デがゲームにあるみたいに幽霊
ガンとか水バンとかはちゃめちゃなことは
ないと思いたいえあるのそれはまあ進んで
みないとそうそうですよね
もうまあ0番戻りたくないですよ結構さ2
番で行き
ますはいはいはいはいまここまではいつも
の
うん大丈夫
そう
禁煙さっき開いてたドアが閉まっている
初め社長が学園祭にやって
くる第一高等学校江川花火
大会82回8月2
日のも
うんあぶねえマジで見落とすかと思った
変わってるなこれ美しいものを美しいと
思えるあなたの心は終わってるって書いて
あるあれさっきあなたの心は美しいだった
気がするけど
いや
危ねえ異変見つけましたはいこ絶対絶対
ここ絶対こここれ異変なので引き返し
ます
はいよしよし戻ってきたぞ3番出口まで
戻ってきましたあと4567185回
か先が長いですけども頑張っていき
ましょうちょっと早めにあの皆さんこれ
やらせなしでやってますか本当に俺何も
知らずに変探しに行ってるんで3番行き
ましょう
うんぱっと見はまあ
禁煙髪型
一生ドアも閉まって
いる学園さにやって
くる大会けも
一緒うん戻ってますね美しに戻ってます
ああやばいわからんわから
ん大丈夫だよねこんな男太かったっ
け男子トイレの男ってこんなずしで構えて
たっ
け床とかも見た方がいい
な大丈夫大丈夫
ここも口じっと
裏から見てもそうだねオッケ
オッケーえここにコンセントあったっけ
やばい
ああわかん
ない大丈夫
丈大丈夫大丈夫大丈夫
あうん多分大丈夫
て
はい異変なしだと思いたいですない気がし
ます大丈夫大丈夫大丈夫このまませみ
ます
頼む怖い怖い怖い怖い
よし初めてってことは
折り返しはい来てるねこれ8番手口はね
あと
5678行けるぞ
[音楽]
よし歯抜けそう自分に変が起きてるじゃあ
4番行きますいやここで見せびたく
[拍手]
うわ
すっご
ええなんか怖いんだけど本当
オレンジどうなってんのこれ禁煙の看板が
もう散乱し
てるすげえあのね楽しい出たいとかじゃ
なくてリアル8番出口が
楽しいすげえなこれはどう見ても異変なの
で引き返します絶対5番になって
[音楽]
ますあと
678あと3つはい来てる来てる来てる
よしじゃあ次は5番
出口
ああ
これ靴入ってないね異変発見しましたなん
でだろうなんか実写だとさめっちゃ分かり
やすいじゃん多分あれ誰でも分かると思う
んだけどゲームの8番出口こういうの
すごい気づかないんだよ戻り
ますき
たえこれ戻れちゃうけどいいもうクリアし
たいこれゼになったら普通に泣くちょっと
マジで本気でクリアしてきます6番出口
行ってき
ます
いやあバットにわからん
な
うん
禁煙ドのも大丈夫これもいつも
通りここも大丈夫
花火大会も大丈夫
そうこれもさっき出たから大丈夫
でしょ大丈夫
うん大丈夫
はい行けてそうだけど
な
こ怖いけど
多分異変なしな気がします異変
なしすぐ行き
ますいやそうだと思いたいんだけど
な出
[音楽]
ます
おおやった7番7番7番マジでってるって
ことは今のは異変
なしこクリアしちゃいますよあと2回か7
番と最後8番クリアして出れるのであと2
回7番行き
ますうわパっと見は分からないやつだ
[音楽]
な
金元ノ
[音楽]
スモーキング俺こんな顔だっ
け俺こんな顔だっ
けやば自分の顔見すぎててなんか分かん
なくなってきたの8月2日第82回大丈夫
俺も大丈夫
看板出口の
看板大丈夫
やばいマジでこういうの一番
不安この
何分かりづらい系の変が
一番困る見たくない本当にやばいマジ
でやばいこの花火の柄こんなんだっけ
こんなんだっけ花火やばいマジで
やばい
やばいえ
やばいどうしようどうしよう本当に分から
ん本当に分からん
いや
やばいこの第7番出口だからこそ
の迷いを生じてます異変ないとは思ってる
んですよあった時のリスクがやばいまた0
からでしょう
そうです無理
いや大丈夫
家ない
です出ます
ね大丈夫だ
ないやさすが
にあれこんなあったっけやばいもがわから
んえあったっけこんなんうわもっと金のと
かも見てった大丈夫変なし出ます
頼むやば怖い見れない
もう嘘だろえ
マジ異変あっ
たありましたえ俺そこ見てたちなみに見て
ました嘘でしょ
え
もうここ
オレンジどうしようどうしようやばいまた
0番で近ですね分かりましたちょっと本当
にやばいマジやばい地獄のゲームだこれ
よし行くぞあちなみにこれあれですか同じ
異変は来ます来る時もありますなるほど
分かりましたそうだゲームもそんな感じ
だったもんね行き
ましょうずまく力です行くよもう終わら
せるよ本当にマジで終わらせるやば何が
異変だったかわかんないのが一番
困るなん
だうんノースモーキング
やばいよ本当にやばいよあああ危ねえこれ
場所逆になってます学園さんやってくる
ポスタがこっちだった花火がこっちよし
変よし1番に戻ってきまし
たどんどん行っていいもう水を恐れない
気持ちが大事食感を信じていきましょう
1番出口行きます頼む
ぜもうすぐ行きます2番出口行き
ましょう
さあサクっと行きたい
よ大丈夫
[音楽]
うん大丈夫
トイレット大丈夫
[音楽]
にやってくる大丈夫ええええ
[拍手]
やばいい見です行きます3番
出口
さあ
大丈夫
か禁煙ノー
スモーキング
えあめっちゃ誰か手でやってたそれでは
行き
ます何何何何いいえぐい
異変変
異変
やばいやスーパーいい変んなこれ5番手口
きました行き
ます遅いなこんなペースだっ
けうん異変ですねよし6番できましたこっ
から勝負だねあと3回
678行きます俺家で何やってんだよ本当
に大丈夫
うん大丈夫
おおひっくり返ってるひっくり返っ
てるハグで八口でになっ
てるこれ逆になってるなよし異変
発見異変です
[音楽]
これよ
よし7番出口まで来ましたよ戻ってきまし
た結構長い時間やってますけどもそろそろ
マジで脱出したい行きましょう7番出口
ですお願いし
ますさすがにそろそろ難しくなってくるん
じゃないか大丈夫
[音楽]
うん俺こんな鼻でかかったっ
けやばいもうわかんなくなってきた枝が
花火
大会初2回永遠な思い出を8月2日金曜日
はいも合っ
てるやばい本当にやばいマジでやばい本当
にやばい
やーやばいわからんどうしようこれは
大丈夫だよ
ね大丈夫
あこの模様はやっぱずっとこだったん
だやばいどうしよう本当
にどうしよう
[音楽]
本当に
やばい本当に
やばいそろそろ
辛い
ああああああああああ
ああ
これ
は異変
なし大丈夫です行くぞ減まし
たこれは正常なオレンチの1階な出ます
さよなら頼むここ超えないともうそもそも
が無理本当にはい
[拍手]
あ
どこあっ
たありましたえ分かりやすい結構むいです
えちょっと待って本当に出れない
やばい
ええヒントくれませんかね多分過去3回
ぐらい本当に何も分からないやつがあった
んですけどもしよかったらのヒントとか
もらえるとちょっと嬉しいかなとか思っ
ちゃったり過去全部間違えてるのは
はいポスター系
ですあの3つの
はいマジ
で
マジいやなんか俺の顔怪しいなと思ったん
だけど元が何かは分かんなくてちょっと
困ったなだめだもう進むしかないやり
ましょう行き
ます0番で口からですねえもうおかしく
なっちゃう本当
に地獄のゲームじゃん
これ速度は大丈夫
髪の毛大丈夫大丈夫問題ない大丈夫
ちょっとちゃんと覚えよこの顔とかをこれ
なんだよな
ちょっとこの2枚この2枚がちょっと何か
が変わってる気がするんだよなこれは
大丈夫異常なし出
ます本当にそうだよないや0回目は結構
着替にいっちゃう大丈夫変化なし出
ます怖い異変なしが怖いオー1番口行き
[音楽]
ますなんかでかく
ね
えっと
2番口行き
ます
うん大丈夫
イレやって
くるうんオッケー大丈夫
異変なし行き
ますよしよしよしよしよし3番行き
ましょうさあ
来いめっちゃ早い4番出口行きますうわ
めちゃ早いめちゃ早い5番出口行き
ます
あれ来なくねいや絶対いつも来るタイけ
ない
会社行くのが嫌になっちゃったのかな6番
行き
ます
[音楽]
うん
禁煙大丈夫
[音楽]
日吉
青春大丈夫
大丈夫
[音楽]
えうん大丈夫大丈夫大丈夫
うん大丈夫
本当
にいや大丈夫大丈夫
本当に大丈夫か本当に大丈夫だよねもう
無理だよ本当にミスったら本当に無理出
ます
よしよしよしよしよしよし来たぞもう
ミスりたくねえよ本当に
行こう7番のその
先
いや問題
[音楽]
なしあれこんなでかかったっけいやわかん
ないもうわかんないやば本当にもうね78
回もう全部疑わしいのよ奥まで行って
みよう1
回露骨に分かりやすい何かがあればいいん
だけどいやないよ
な
いやあやばいこの大きさがちょっとあれで
もこんなもんだった気もする
ないややっぱでかくなってる気がする
なんか印刷が荒く見えるんだよないやこれ
はポスターがちょっと大きくなってる気が
するこれは異変ありポスターがちょっと
大きくなってる気がします引き返し
ますお願いしますお願いしますお願いし
ますお願いします
888やったええ8になってる8になっ
てるえ
ポスターポスターです本当の違いは
はさんの鼻の大きさですおいなんだよそれ
なんか違和感を感じてて画素数が荒く感じ
たからその大きさが変わったかなと思って
たんですけど鼻大きくなってたんなるほど
まま異変には気づけたので問題ない
でしょうさあラスト8
番これにクリアすれば出れるということ
ですねそうですではラスト8番出口行き
[拍手]
ます
いやぱっと見
[音楽]
は大丈夫そうだ
けどうーん
[音楽]
初め第1高学校学園祭熱血青春高木文化の
花開く合ってる合ってる合っ
てる82回枝川花火大会この夏永遠の
思い出よ2028月2日金曜日19時21
時場所枝川運結構枝川町観光教会あっ
てる美しいもの美しいと思えるあなたの心
は美しい恥合ってるいここも合ってる
ぞ合っ
てるなんだ
もっと最後だから相当難しい気がするんだ
よなめっちゃやばい何かが入ってるとか
ないよ
[音楽]
な
こういうあの遺が増えてたのは異変です
かこれは異変じゃありません異変じゃない
かいやこれ
はポスターは絶対大丈夫でした確信を持っ
て言えますそれ以外の部分も結構見たん
です
けど多分大丈夫
[音楽]
これ家ない
です
[拍手]
[音楽]
頼ま本当にお願いお願いします本当にお
願いし
ます怖い
8万
[音楽]
[拍手]
レ